James B Stewart author of the book den
of thieves on the cover of your book it
starts out by saying this once upon a
time in the 80s for men nearly destroyed
Wall Street who were those four men well
their characters have I'd been dreaming
them up like I couldn't have done it
I'll go from the small fraud of the big
enchilada at the lower end is Demma
Sylvain an investment banker who was
accused by the SEC of making twelve
point six million dollars in insider
trading profits next up the wrong Martin
Segal at the time the lead country's
leading investment banker star mergers
specialist he ended up paying over
eleven million dollars in penalties then
there was his co-conspirator Ivan Boesky
the country's leading arbitrage or
probably the best-known name on Wall
Street in the mid 80s he paid a fine and
penalty of a hundred million dollars and
finally there was Michael Milken the
junk bond King and his fun and penalty
was six hundred million dollars you know
one of the things that popped out of me
in this book was when you're going over
what happened to these folks you write
that in September Denis Levine was
excited that he's going to be on 60
minutes
well that's happened and how did you
know that when you wrote the book oh I
was working on the epilogue obviously
the last thing I wrote in the book and I
was probably working on that late this
summer and the 60 Minutes producer had
been calling a number of people I had
interviewed for the book who called me
to say that they were they were working
on something to do with Denis Levine and
you think Denis Levine would've been
happy or was he happy with the report on
60 no he was thrilled but I mean there
was one of the lines I loved in the book
is that with his life collapsing around
him having been caught up in this game
Denis Levine turns to one of his
co-conspirators and says you know none
of this matters as long as you're famous
that point he hopped out of his car and
rushed up to the newsstand because he
had heard his picture was going to be on
the cover of Newsweek he was thrilled by
this well turned out his picture wasn't
on the cover
Newsweek it was inside the magazine and
he was very disappointed about that but
he had also said to many people that his
real dream was to be on 60 minutes and
well he did achieve it have you met all
these men I've met all of these yes
how many have maybe interviewed well I'm
reluctant to get into who I did or did
an interview for the book because by
process of elimination then you can
figure out who the major sources were
and I have made some promises not to
reveal that on the other hand at various
times I have open to all characters in
the story which of the four would you
sit down to for dinner some night if you
had time on your hands and just want to
be entertained well it depends on what
you're looking for uh there's no doubt
in my mind that the nicest guy of the
four is Martin Siegel in my view he is
the one who had found true remorse and
it's trying to make amends for what
getting italy did wrong and what he did
wrong is very serious what do you see in
the story he blatantly insider traded
not open only with Ivan Boesky but with
the head of arbitrage a goldman sachs
bob frame and he admitted to all of that
and he surrounded that with some very
tawdry dealings he took suitcases of
cash that were handed off both in the
lobby of the Plaza Hotel in New York and
one very bizarre encounter at a pay
phone booth on a street in Manhattan so
he he diddled he did a lot of bad things
did he go to jail he did go to jail
though he got the lightest jail term of
these four he spent only two months in
prison and he's out now he's though he
is working very hard now to rebuild his
life and he is devoting himself to
community service activities in
Jacksonville Florida and he always was a
very charming engaging personality as
part of his success on Wall Street and
he still is however if you want a sort
of an expend an evening with an
eccentric character that you'll end up
talking about probably the rest of your
life I guess I'd have to pick boesky he
is a pretty bizarre guy one of the
things that struck me about him was the
lavishness of his lifestyle and spending
it's just it's just incredible
he'd go to a restaurant and when the
waiter came by and would say well these
are our specials today Boesky would say
well I'll have all of them he'd order
every special on the menu 810 didn't
make any difference and so they'd have
to wheel a whole separate table out with
all the day's dishes on and boesky would
circle the table he taste each dish pick
one
send all the rest back he'd pay for all
of them of course money was no object
did he go to jail he did go to jail he
was sentenced to three years he was
released welcomed County his jail time
and then his halfway house time he
served approximately two years in
confinement
he's out now what's he doing he is
living most of his time in Europe now
he's he has separated from his wife who
continues to live on the lavish boskie
estate in Westchester County New York he
is spending most of his time in France
in Paris on the Cote d'Azur he has an
apartment in Paris in a house on the
Riviera he spends much of his time with
this very peculiar character named who
Shang WA Kili who has been his sort of
mysterious lifelong companion and he has
been trying to raise some money so far
unsuccessfully to get back into some
kind of securities business of the four
who would you least like to spend an
evening with I guess I'd have to say for
purely social time milk and he was he's
so obsessed with his work that he rarely
socialized I mean he was no one who
could really divert his attention from
making money to having an ordinary
conversation with the likes of you or me
again a just one of the zillions of
anecdotes illustrating this is that the
the traders and salesmen who worked in
his office decided to celebrate his
birthday by hiring a stripper to come
into the office and the stripper was
doing her act when the phone rang for
milking it was a client wanting to
execute a junk bond trade Milken took
the call and then when he was distracted
by the stripper he actually crawled
under his trading desk and the stripper
who by now had taken all of her clothes
off crawled under the desk after him
and he still managed to stay on the
phone and complete the tread
even with this pandemonium going on
around him he was compulsive and what
happened to him he is of the four he's
the only one currently in jail now he
was sentenced to a 10-year term the most
severe of the group and he is in federal
prison in Pleasanton California outside
of San Francisco right now let me read
the last couple paragraphs in your book
there was a moment of stunned silence
his lawyers suddenly realized that
Milken hearing he was being sentenced to
two years on each of the various counts
hadn't understood he'd been given
consecutive sentences Lyman broke the
news Lyman being Arthur Lyman of Iran
Contra fain yes and did I'll get back to
that but you say here Lyman broke the
news ten years Michael he said gently
the sentence is ten years you go on the
blood drain from Milken's face
he took Lori's arm his wife Worth and
the two disappeared into a small
witnesses waiting room off the corridor
closing the door behind them moments
later first Lauri and then Milken
emitted blood-curdling screams Sandler
burst into the room as Milken collapsed
into a chair hyperventilating struggling
for breath oxygen someone yelled as a
federal marshal raced for help how do
you know that happened that was that
those few paragraphs probably took more
time to piece together from a reporting
standpoint than just about anything else
in the book I can say that the account
ultimately came from eyewitnesses I
first heard about this bizarre ending to
the Milken saga from someone who was not
present but had heard accounts of it
that began to circulate from the very
small number of people who were present
when it happened I guess beyond that I
don't want to say specifically who in
the entourage gave me these details I
did attempt to interview and in some
case exceeded everyone who was present
in that corridor during those moments
and I think you can tell from the level
of detail that I was able to get
pretty comprehensive account monitor is
I have to say that if someone read the
book and called me and said you know I
just can't believe it I just I just
don't believe that it's just too bizarre
and I just want to say that no no one
has contradicted this no one has denied
that this happened it did happen exactly
like that what's it mean I think it's a
the meaning to me is it has an almost
sort of a literary sense to it it is
this was the downfall of a man who had
been richer and more powerful than just
about anyone in the business world in
this decade and the final realization
that he had been destroyed was
exceptionally anguishing event and I
think the level of the emotion the
extreme reaction to this news showed the
powers of denial that had gone up until
this point which is very evident as you
as you read the story and then that
sudden awareness of how far he had
fallen it was just an overwhelming
overpowering kind of reaction to that
turn of fate which I believe until that
moment milk and believed never could
happen a little tidbit you put in the
book that in prison he's not allowed to
wear his hairpiece yes that's right has
to wear a baseball cap or does wear a
base B chooses to wear a baseball cap
you know do you learn anything about why
the men like this wears a hairpiece or
what well he he was very concerned about
his appearance and very sensitive about
the fact that he was bald at a very
early age he had an earlier hairpiece
which you see in the initial picture in
the book which was not very artfully
done and there came a time and it seemed
as though there was a period in his life
when these things didn't bother him very
much but then later as he became much
more wealthy and successful in hobnob
with some of the richest people in
America he did become more concerned
with his appearance and he you know and
the trappings of wealth and power and as
part of that transformation he did get
this much more expensive and much better
done
era piece but I'm not a psychiatrist or
a psychologist I think there probably is
some significance to that but precisely
what it is I couldn't picture view on
the back of the book where were you born
I was born in the Midwest a small city
right on the banks to the Mississippi
River Quincy Illinois
Hannibal Missouri which was Mark Twain's
home is right across the river that was
always a big rivalry between Quincy and
Hannibal and I really grew up with Mark
Twain lore Mark Twain's stories and
visiting the Mark Twain cave and I guess
my first interested in storytelling got
started with Mark Twain you go to high
school there yes Quincy High School was
one high school one public high school
for the town and that's where I was who
taught you about Mark Twain there was a
wonderful wonderful English teacher
named Marjorie bolt who had a tremendous
influence on me I guess maybe everyone
has had this experience one high school
teacher that just made the world come to
life and she could do that and I just
loved her her class her English classes
she always said read read read she was
constantly shoving books into our hands
and she was so enthusiastic about it
I still remember that very vividly who
was Mark Twain Oh Samuel Clemens well he
was a you know great I mean what was he
to you besides just - oh he was he took
the the substance of the world around
him and wove it into this he's gripping
narratives I mean I you know I know he's
deemed as kind of symbol symbol of
Americana I don't know if he really
thought of himself in those terms but he
was a real a realist and a humorist and
he took the materials of life around him
and created these great stories
I mean he had a wonderful imagination
and some of his works or or more
fictional and imaginative than others
but I still think at its core he was
doing much the same thing he looked at
the world around him and that's what
inspired these stories where'd you go to
college I went to DePaul University in
Greencastle Indiana an even smaller town
in the Midwest why'd you pick that I
don't know I think I visit very school
so I always wanted to go to a small
liberal arts college that was my idea
what college was all about small classes
lots of interaction with professors lots
of talking about the big issues of the
day of the past and you know a nice
setting with leafy trees I always
thought there'd be plenty of time to see
the world I wanted to see it but I I
somehow felt start with the foundation
of it comes from thinking and then go
out and then you'll be armed to absorb
what you see see around you so I visited
a number of small colleges growing up in
a town like Quincy not not that many
people went far away to college no one
that in my knowledge ever went to the
east coast or the west coast maybe some
where as far away as Colorado most of my
graduating class went into the family
farming businesses and didn't go to
college it'll even go as far away's as
de pau if I visit and I liked it looked
it was exactly what I had been looking
for and would you stand out to be oh I
was a social sciences major I I was a
political science major then I broadened
it into it what was called an area major
which will still had his core in
political science expanded into history
and Romance languages branch and how did
you get to the wall street journal' well
I
after college I went to law school and
then I worked for a law firm in New York
City and that the big leap in my career
came in 1979
I decided to move from practicing law to
writing about lawyers at a new magazine
that hadn't even started called American
Lawyer magazine I helped get that off
the ground and stayed there for four and
a half years wrote my first book about
lawyers it was called the partners and
shortly after that I wrote a letter to
The Wall Street Journal because I loved
that front page stories I to me then in
journalism that's where you could be a
storyteller and a reporter at the same
time I didn't know anybody there and
they called me in for an interview and
eventually I got hired a couple of quick
things what law school Harvard Law
School what years did you get out of
DePauw and Harvard and what year did you
start at the journal I graduated from
DePaul in 1973 and started Harvard that
same year and graduated there in 1976
and I was at a large law firm Cravath
Swaine and Moore for about three years
and started American lawyer 1979 and
when did you go The Journal 1983 in the
front part of your book you have a
dedication and it's for Jane my sister
Michael my brother and for Kate yes why
that particular dedication oh well I
hadn't I had I didn't know I wanted to
get everyone in I guess who I felt we're
very close in who I love very much and
so I put my brother and sister and my
sisters three years younger than I am
and really grew up grew up together and
remained quite close my brother is much
younger he recently graduated from
college and so we've had a very
interesting relationship that's not like
most fraternal ones since I'm so much
older and then Kate as a baby as my
goddaughter is the who was born well two
of my closest friends while I was busy
writing this book so it seemed only
fitting to include her as well I kind of
have three generations and that
dedication den of thieves is the title
of your book words that come from oh
it's a biblical reference the passage
where Jesus has come into the temple and
says this was a it was written this is a
house of prayer and you have made it
thieves and it it works for me as the
title on a number of levels primarily of
course that the main characters in this
story are thieves both literally in the
sense that they stole confidential
information and made money off of it and
thieves in the broader sense that they
hatched schemes that separated millions
and millions of dollars of other
people's money that ended up in their
pockets but because they were
undermining the integrity of the market
I don't think it's an accident that the
stock market in New York looks like a
temple it has those classical columns
lining the front and the market presents
itself as an institution of integrity of
the rule of law just as the temple
itself was holding itself to a higher
standard biblical times so I found that
the since the stock exchange itself had
embraced this kind of temple imagery
that it worked very well in terms of the
underlying biblical passage also I don't
mean to be too literal about this I I
was trying to suggest as well that there
is at its core there is a moral theme in
this story that it's not just a book
about Wall Street but it's really a
story about human nature and temptation
and its consequences your current job at
The Wall Street Journal I'm the editor
of the front page
how long have you done that since
September of 1988 so how long is that no
I guess a little over three years how
did you have time to write this book and
to do that at the same time i I don't
know myself sometimes but typically my
day was I would get into the office you
know 8:30 or 9:00 in the morning and
work until about 2:00 I try to cram a
full day's work into that period of time
but then leave to my wonderful staff
there polishing up the rest of the day
then I'd race home grab a bite to eat
and usually be riding by 3:00 say in the
afternoon and I'd go till about 9:00 and
then I'd have dinner and six hours a day
is about intense writing it's about all
I can do I would find
my Stan and I kind of went off a cliff
at that point and that filled up my life
pretty fully I don't necessarily
recommend that that regimen but I also
took some sometimes I was just riding so
intense that I couldn't go into work and
I took some days well when did you start
this book I began the reporting back
when Dennis Levine was arrested and in
May of 1986 I agreed to do the book I
knew it was going to be a big story and
it was going to be more but late in 1986
I agreed to do the book I continued to
do reporting on and off up through last
year a lot of new information came to
the surface after first Drexel and then
Milken pleaded guilty I actually sat
down to write the first paragraph and I
think June last summer and started
typing and really worked very intensely
straight through until I finished the
following February with two big
interruptions one was when Iraq invaded
Kuwait on August 2nd that day will
always be etched in my mind and then
that kind of stabilized and I was able
to get back to the book and then I was
sprinting to the finish line getting it
written when the war broke out in
January and it was very difficult I just
had to take the book and put it on hold
and develop myself full-time to the
paper doing those incredible weeks I'm
happy to say it was a short war how
would you characterize your reaction to
your book
well I it's been in it's been incredible
I I guess I had lived with so much of
this information so long that I'd
forgotten what a jolt it was going to be
to readers there's a tremendous amount
of new stuff in there and I think it's
it explains things and shows the the
gravity of the the threat to the economy
and the magnitude of the crimes in a way
that somehow even much of what was
written in daily journalism didn't
capture so I'm thrilled by that I mean
I'm the an extra brand Wall Street
Journal last week and I've never gotten
response to anything like that that I've
ever written before it has generated
some controversy there are characters in
the book who
are exceptionally unhappy with the way
that they've been portrayed the milk and
camp
I think reasons I do not fully
understand and as I mentioned the
epilogue are still trying to rewrite
history even though he has pleaded
guilty to six felonies they're even
considering the possibility of trying to
come forward and saying well no he he
didn't really do any of that and they're
based on my what I've been able to tell
have have reaction have reacted very
violently against the book I have been
fending off various legal threats and
spending a lot of time going back and
rebutting allegations and I'm happy to
say that even though scores of lawyers
have been pouring over every line in
this book that it has held up completely
under this kind of scrutiny how much
money is mike michael milken although
he's in jail have the best year
knowledge in the bank well i estimate
that he has at least two billion he will
have at least two billion when he comes
out and that's not in coming up with
that number I'm not even attempting to
estimate how much money that two billion
is earning every day because I'm sure
it's in the hands of very shrewd
financial advisers who know how to
maximize the return the numbers are
staggering I mean they are and they're
reveal I think for the most part the
first time in this book because it took
a great deal of reporting on my part in
time to kind of piece this together but
let's just look at one year in 1986
here in 550 million that year in salary
and bonus from Drexel the same year one
of his partnerships he had over 500
secret partnerships in the Beverly Hills
office one of those partnerships paid
out over 400 million in 1986 and one
deal that he worked on and extracted
warrants to buy stock the beatrice deal
I calculate those warrants in 1986 were
worth approximately 650 million dollars
now we're looking at one year salary one
deal he got stock equity in and one of
his partnerships and were well over 1
billion for that year I mean those
numbers just I was flabbergasted how
much might ease Ivan Boesky Hamlet again
the book reveals that in the
confidential
statement that his lawyer submitted at
the time of his sentencing which I
believe has never been revealed before
he indicated a net worth of 125 million
dollars he paid a fine 100 million so
that leaves him with roughly 25 million
dollars however his wife was wealthy in
her own right and there were various
trust funds and other accounts set up to
benefit his children so if you include
those assets as part of the sort of
boesky financial picture and he's much
wealthier even than that on the other
hand 25 million is I mean in the world
of milk and that's poverty in my world
and I suspect yours that's still
enormous well and boskie is living very
well he comes in limousines is still
eating at loot s he's hobnobbing in
Europe
none of the four are are going to be
suffering how much is Janice Levine
worth that's hard to it's hard to figure
out theoretically he paid all of his
assets as part of his settlement but
he's still living comfortably on a Park
Avenue apartment he still took his
family for a two-week vacation in Aspen
this year and I mean where is all this
money coming from I mentioned in the
epilogue to the book that the SEC has
been investigating Levine again to find
out where this money is coming from the
60 minutes show you referred to earlier
raised questions about whether Levine is
in fact engaged in another sort of con
operation and I also suggest in the book
that he had hidden assets of at least
several hundred thousand dollars that he
didn't disclose at the time of his
sentencing and how much is martin Segal
worth that too is hard to estimate he
again purported to pay most of his
assets in fines and settlements at the
time he resolved the charges however he
was allowed to keep all of his real
estate and I do report the numbers on
that he sold his apartment in New York
for well over a million and he sold his
estate in Connecticut for something over
three million
he bought a very beautiful mansion in
Jacksonville Florida but real estate
prices they were much lower so if just
looking at the real estate picture
suggests that he would have several
million dollars left over and again that
seems like a small amount compared to
boats Keys 25 but you know couple
million dollars I think I could get by
rather well on that I want to show the
audience James would look over this page
we'll start up here no over on the other
side here dementias you'll see this I
want to ask you about three people sure
mike milken here sitting next to Edward
Bennett Williams who has since died
since that picture was taken you down
here below and the man in the middle
with Mike Milken is Arthur Lyman right
we saw a lot of during the Iran Contra
hearings and if you go over here you see
Linda gods didn't Robinson and her
husband Jimmy Robinson from American
Express start with Linda Robinson who is
she Linda Robinson heads a public
relations firm that bears her name and
was hired by Milken to conduct the
public relations aspects of this defense
I think it's fair to say that the first
time in history that a individual
defendant in a criminal case mobilized
the media resources that were at the
command of Linda Robinson and her allies
one of the most startling things I found
was that Milken was spending more than
three million dollars a month a month on
his legal and public relations campaign
Drexel itself who had to pay the bills
under an agreement was so outraged they
put him on it you know quote-unquote
budget of 1.2 million a month but he
didn't just spend his own money she is
very powerful she was able to mobilize a
very effective campaign in the press to
this day and I think this book is going
to dispel a lot of it to this day you
still hear lively debates over whether
Milken really did anything wrong I think
that reflects the fact that he had the
this unprecedented campaign going on
orchestrated by Linda Robinson who is
she she is married to James Robinson
who's the chairman of American Express
she worked in the Reagan campaign
she is the daughter of God of her fault
her father was I believe Amos in the
Famous Amos and Andy series and she grew
up in Hollywood and as a child in fact
she used to bounce on Ronald Reagan's
knees and in kind of a mirror of our
times she was I think in the 70s an
acupuncture specialist she then became a
Reagan political activist and then she
moved to New York and Wall Street and
brought Republicans sort of attack style
tactics to the world of public relations
you say that there are three I think it
was the name three people including
George Gilder and Jude Wynette's key it
used to be at the Wall Street Journal
yes and I don't remember the third Peter
Magowan that chairman of Safeway who are
very much doing what and very much in
well they're maintaining a campaign on
behalf of milk and again for reasons
that are escaped me but there is an
organization which I mentioned in the
book that is being run is going around
of all things raising money to try to
clear milken's name and to try to
demonstrate in their own terms that he
was a symbol of compassion and not greed
and of course I feel they are entitled
to their views again I do feel it is
primarily a reflection of how wealthy
milk and made various people did Linda
Robinson do anything to try to stop you
from writing this book or she have any
impact on you know trying to sell you on
the fact that this man was innocent well
yes I mean Linda Robinson and her allies
were trying to convert me to the Milken
cause on an almost daily basis from the
day they were hired to represent Milken
however I think a point came where they
decided that I was I was a hopeless
cause and then they turned they tried to
like shut me out of every bit of
information that they control which they
I think hoped would put me at a
disadvantage and then
remember Linda threatening that the day
Milken was exonerated they were in the
leak that news to the New York Times
which would then scoop the Wall Street
Journal well needless to say such a day
never came but there was that kind of
thing that was going on and then they
they then would let other reporters go
to meet milk and and then freeze me out
or they'd invite all the reporters to
the famous Predators balls going on in
Beverly Hills and of course I'd be
frozen Elton I'd I went to one of them
anyway just to see what was going on and
of course immediately I had people
following me everywhere I went not
letting me get indoors and that kind of
thing
history a couple days ago that your own
newspaper in the senatorial page has
done a lot of defending of Mike Milken
yes and is that true and do you get in
conflict with them as the first disease
one editor features well the some people
don't understand this at The Wall Street
Journal but there's a very strict
separation between the editorial page
people who focus on opinion and the news
people who focus on fact and I'm on the
news side of this operation there's
there in a separate wing of the building
so I rarely if ever even see the people
who work on the editorial page as I
mentioned in the book our editorial page
has written a number of editorials that
are favorable to Milken in various ways
but they come at this from a largely
ideological grounds they are concerned
about they were concerned about the role
of the government in the investigation
and I think you see in my book there are
some legitimate concerns in that they
were concerned about the use of the RICO
statute which to me is not a
particularly significant issue but it's
a legitimate one for debate on their
pages and they are they're also very
interested in the impact that a mill can
had on broader economic issues in the
country again I think a legitimate
subject for opinion and debate on the
other hand what I'm interested in were
the facts and the criminal conspiracy
that underlay all of this and I think
that's incontrovertible as far as the
story goes it is of little interest to
me whether milken's activities in some
sense boost
some sectors of the economy you can
argue that the drug trade by increasing
the velocity of money contributes to the
economy but that doesn't mean we're
going to condemn the drug trade how did
the excerpt from your book find its way
under the front page I think of the
second section of illustrate yes who
made that decision the executive editor
Norman pearl son who runs the paper
ultimately made the decision both to do
the excerpt and and where it should be
but we have in doing book excerpts
traditionally been running them on the
front of the second section of the
marketplace page that's in part because
the publishing industry is traditionally
covered in that section but also because
the display possibilities are really
better there anyone's familiar with the
front page of The Wall Street Journal I
think knows what it looks like and it's
a bit gray and it has a headline format
that is you know oriented towards the
kinds of stories that run there and I
think in the past when book excerpts
have run there it's a it's an awkward
fit into our front page format there's
it happen very often that we do excerpts
it's happening with increasing frequency
I thought I would say I remember a Bryan
Burrough and John Hellyer's excerpt from
barbarians at the gate was given a very
good display on that page and more
recently Alex Kotlowitz as book on the
housing projects in Chicago that no
children here was displayed there and me
ask you about Edward Bennett Williams
why is he sitting next to Mike Milken
and where is he well they were at a at
that picture there was a congressional
hearing run by a congressman Dingell
into the operations of these secret
partnerships in Beverly Hills it was the
first public appearance by Milken after
the investigation so it was enormous
attention there Edward Bennett Williams
was hired by Milken as his primary
defense counsel at the beginning of the
investigation and Edward billions
Bennett Williams was the lead lawyer
Arthur Lyman and his colleagues appalled
wise at that point we're co-counsel but
we're very much in a second chair role
and the book explores in considerable
detail and I believe that had Edward
Bennett Williams lived the outcome of
this might have been very
friend why well Edward Bennett Williams
was always a little more skeptical of
some of the claims being made by milk
and his supporters Milken was portraying
himself as a quote national treasure
unquote as a genius as this man who had
single-handedly unleashed these great
creative forces in the American economy
and Milken has always been surrounded by
people who told him what he wanted to
hear and that extended a minute his
lawyers but Edward Bennett Williams was
not that kind of lawyer and I'm
confident from talking to people very
close to the operation that as the
evidence mounted as clearly the tide was
turning against Milken Edward Bennett
Williams would have had the sense to
recognize that and get Milken in earlier
to cut a deal one of the revelations of
the book is that in fact Milken was
offered to deal to only two felonies and
try to accept it but in his arrogance or
indecision or whatever he missed the
deadline and when he missed the deadline
the prosecutor said we're sorry you know
that deal is on what were the politics
of Edward Bennett Williams I believe he
was a lifelong Democrat but he he
represented a wide range of clients with
different political views I think that
wasn't of any great concern to him when
it came to defending a high-profile case
and Arthur Lyman at what time was Arthur
Lyman involved in this whole thing well
Arthur Lyman was hired at the same time
as Edward Bennett Williams but in a
secondary capacity and once Edward wind
of billions became increasingly ill
Lyman stepped forward and then then took
charge
I believe Williams died in August of
1989 and after that alignment came to
the fore and when was Michael Milken
actually convicted he finally pleaded
guilty in March of 1990 and he was
sentenced in November of 1990 and at do
you remember when the iran-contra
hearings were in there and how did that
interfere with Arthur Lyman's work well
there there was a get a lull in the case
I again I believe that those were the
summer of 1989
I could be off a year on that but he was
able to get away and and conduct those
and then get back to the case there was
some sort of lengthy and somewhat
tedious discovery processes going on in
the case at that time but he always
remained firmly in control the defense
lawmen at the time this judge was
somewhat I don't want to call her
controversial but she was talked about a
lot and why and who is it well this is
judge Kimbell wood who is the sentencing
judge and continuing to preside over
efforts to reduce Milkin sentence she
was new I think the the mystery about
Kimball wood was that there wasn't a
record there to turn to to get much of a
sense of how she would rule in
sentencing she was a reagan appointee
and which you know but how are we going
to read that in the criminal context I
mean some Reagan supporters have been
very supportive of milk and has some
kind of free-market ear I think
wrongheaded Lee but nonetheless honestly
held conviction all the Reagan
supporters are very strong that we you
know on the sentencing aspect in
criminal cases that you need a harsh
sentence to deter this kind of conduct
so which side was she going to come down
on there was tremendous speculation
about this prior to the verdict I think
adding to this is that she has a very
gracious and gentle demeanor she was
very soft-spoken during the sentencing
hearing she sounded very solicitous to
Milken's feelings and concerns but then
again she dropped this sentence which
was the most severe in the insider
trading scandal now I think when you
when people read the book and they see
the magnitude of what Milken did wrong
this sentence does not seem unduly out
of line but given the milk and PR that
he was this genius this National
Treasury just stepped over the line a
few times here and there it did seem
like a harsh sentence judge wood is
married to Michael Kramer of Time
magazine yes I believe so and I asked
you a question about all this a moment
because I want to also show this
gentleman who jumped into politics here
not too long ago but lost right what
office did he run for you ran for mayor
and I believe he may run again and who
is he
Rudolph Guiliani a former US attorney in
Manhattan
what role did he play in all this well
he oversaw most of the the criminal
investigation from his position at the
top of the office and I feel he does
that he deserved credit for the fact
that in fact these four major major
culprits were eliminated from the
securities industry on the other hand I
think you see in the passage of the book
he was zealous to the point where I
believe his his obsession with the ends
obscured some of the means the
government did not behave at the high
standards I think most of us have a
right to expect why two things
particularly stand out to me there was a
fight between Giuliani and Gary Lynch
head of enforcement at the SEC over the
following in the Milkin case and when
the SEC for its own reasons and I think
good ones wanted to go forward with the
case Giuliani was so angry that he said
if they did that he'd throw his lot in
with milk and drexell and moved to
dismiss the action now I I just found
that I'm sure it was said in a moment of
anger and thoughtlessness but that
simply is inappropriate the SEC did give
in to Julie on his threat and they
waited and there was also the story
which I find quite fascinating and
dramatic where a government agent posed
as a blackmailer and made anonymous
phone calls to Siegel terrorizing him
into running to the government and
pleading guilty I simply don't think
those tactics are necessary that I think
the requests their questionable from a
policy standpoint but more to the point
it just simply the government should not
be resorting to a form of crime itself
in order to bring criminals and all
along through this process did you find
that any of these men who were convicted
of what would you say the overall
climate was well its securities fraud it
starts with insider trading and then
you'll see particularly milken's case
it's a whole superstructure of crimes
that build on that were they giving much
money to politicians for any reason the
Drexel Milken camp did contribute to
politicians to various PACs Wall Street
was a heavy contributor to Senator
D'Amato who of course replaced Giuliani
eventually with a
US attorney that's apparently more to
his is locking the exact numbers I can't
remember off the top of my head although
that's all it's all disclosed in in the
book yes there were heavily political
contributions who's this man Fred Joseph
he was the chief executive of Drexel
during the Milken reign one of the
peculiarities of Drexel was it's sort of
fictitious a overt system a firm
regulation milk and was not an officer
of the farm he had no title he was not
on the board of directors and yet milk
and Rand Rand Drexel and he lived
drexels head court in New York and he
lived yes and he he lived on the west
coast far far away from the scrutinizing
odds that someone like for a Joseph I
must say I feel a certain sympathy for
Joseph he may have been failed to show
the kind of leadership in crisis that
was needed to save that firm but he was
dealing with a fourth in Milken that the
financial world had never seen before I
mean the numbers pouring in or just so
staggering overall question about this
in your in the Wall Street Journal your
editorial page was saying good things
about Michael Milken the judge is
married to a Time magazine correspondent
the PR person is involved in Republican
politics
Arthur Lyman's serve the Democrats and
the ran contrary are we all so well
served by all of these conflicts of
interest I'm not suggesting that just
because the judge is married at Time
magazine correspondent is a conflict of
interest but you see what I'm getting at
here I mean do you feel good about the
process the I think the question here is
that I tried to examine to some extent
in the book is what happens when you
have someone so wealthy and so powerful
who is a defendant in a criminal case
does this does the system really work
does it does it treat this defendant the
same way it would if you or I without
this kinds of resources were charged
with the crime and I think the answer
the the broad answer is and I think we
should be heartened by this that it did
work that this was a tremendous
challenge to the American system of
justice and while you might quibble
about the fairness of the ultimate sent
this sentence the fact is I do believe
the process worked
now what did it work that way for you
and I know clearly I mean there
normos forces brought to bear here such
enormous forces that at one point Gary
Lynch the head of the SEC felt like
resigning that he was so overwhelmed did
some people who should have been
prosecuted get away with with white
punishment or not at all
yes in other words is the system perfect
no but I myself was actually heartened
to see but all of these forces arrayed
against truth and justice that I do
believe the truth has prevailed page 381
Connie Brooke
yes tell that story well mine is the
most the first book about all the
criminal wrongdoing but is not the first
book about Milken and Drexel Connie
Brock who happens to be a friend of mine
someone I know reasonably well did a
book on Drexel Milken called the
Predators ball looking into their to
their methods and they put on a
full-court press to try to try to stop
this book and went to went to great
lengths to try to block it at one point
Arthur Lyman was insisting the Drexel
sue to try to try to stop this even
before it was published although I'm
sure he realized that that was a losing
case under the First Amendment but again
the book got out and the book got
written and wasn't blocked what about
this line why don't you we pay you the
commitment fee that your publisher would
have paid you except we'll pay it to you
not to write the book who did that that
was milk and that wasn't out not when
you know when other methods failed it
was not no attempt abroad Connie into
giving up the book what do you think of
the lawyers and the politicians going
back and forth on different sides in
this thing I mean who ever you know at
one moment you see Arthur Lyman in front
of a committee that's asking tough
questions of that whole process in
iran-contra the next moment you see him
involved in representing a Mike Milken
client and they always say well
everybody deserves an attorney's that's
a fair system
well it's it's confusing
me people and it takes it takes an
astute observer I think you know you see
an Arthur Lyman coming forward as the
champion of of truth and democracy as
the interrogator of someone in the
Congress and then that aura carries over
when you see him coming forward and
saying that Mike Milken is is a national
treasure now the fact of the matter is
these are very different roles it's
Arthur Lyman acting as a public servant
on behalf of Congress and then he's
turning around is the paid advocate for
someone we now know to mitad to having
been a crime when he's wearing his
Milken hat now I don't know what the
answer to that is I just think it
requires an alert and it's too public
that not to be taken in in by this
there's no question I mean this a better
source and I can explore this sort of
revolving door idea but many of the
highest paid and and best lawyers in the
country have worked in government
service have taken on this sort of aura
The Statesman like maybe increasing with
stateswoman like or which they then turn
around and sell to the highest bidder
and I think that has raised many
questions that continue to be explored
looking at the process now that you've
written this book and you look back at
it who stars in your opinion who are the
heroes oh the heroes I think without
question are the very low paid
incredibly hard-working dedicated public
servants not at the top necessarily but
who did the real work in the US
Attorney's Office and the Securities
Exchange Commission and I think it's
worth bearing in mind that with the
enormous forces arrayed against them
there were there was no great political
support for their work where ordinarily
you would turn for for some kind of
backing that the sense of the American
public was on your side the only thing
they really had was the truth and they
were determined to get it out and I have
tremendous respect for their continuing
to do that under very difficult
circumstances how about the public
figures anybody shine there as far as
you're concerned well the no not
particularly it was a this is a drama
that was largely largely played out
outside of the public arena with except
of the with the law enforcement units on
the other hand I think what has been
remiss is the kind of attention I mean
Legislature should have woken up to what
was going on on Wall Street in the 80s
admittedly we were all perhaps a little
bit slow to realize the magnitude of the
kinds of deals that were happening in
the opportunity for crime of us on a
scale that had never been seen on Wall
Street before and I say in the epilogue
that there are laws that need to be
toughened on this I mean we now the
Salomon scandal is raging as long as
Wall Street traders measure risk and
reward and decide that the rewards
outweigh the risk they're going to do
things are going to break the law and so
the risk of getting caught has to be
made clear I do think we need a
definition of insider trading and I
think the financial penalties in these
crimes need to be increased the press
yes what do you think of the press's
performers during this whole story well
I was part of it I have to admit and
then I I guess I I'd like to say that I
was particularly proud of the The Wall
Street Journal slugging away on this and
trying to write the facts I mean I I can
tell you that there were numerous
numerous attempts by powerful people in
Wall Street to get me and at my
colleague at the time Dan
Hertzberg not only off this story but
fired from our jobs and the chairman of
dal Jones Warren Phillips and my boss
Norm prole Stein staunchly supported us
during all of this and there was a great
deal of good coverage that came out of
the press now was there also some
members of the press who were all too
easily manipulated by the public
relations forces I believe there were
there were some who for ideological
reasons wanted to believe the Milken law
and whatever the whatever the facts
really were and then there were others
who who succumbed all too easily to
these promises of access that were to a
great figure like Milken that we're
emanating from
Robinson Lake Camp if you had more pages
to devote to all this what would you
have included in this book that you
didn't well the original manuscript did
have more pages and I I credit my editor
Alice min here with very wisely cutting
down some of this stuff I did go into in
the original book more detail in in the
attempts of the milking camp to
obfuscate the facts for example in this
hearing that was held late in the
process and about 100 pages of the
manuscript got cut out of that but I
suppose I I could have gone on forever
working on on this book there are still
some mysteries hanging out there the
whole the whole thing began to unravel
with this mysterious anonymous letter
that rolled into Merrill Lynch from
Caracas Venezuela which in itself is a
fascinating story to this day no one
knows who wrote that letter if I had
endless time in space I would have you
know just kept tracking after that until
I found found the the author of that
mysterious letter you have ended book
you're thinking right at the moment I
don't I've been working on this for five
years and it was an intensely draining
experience not only because of the work
schedule I described earlier but it's
because of the the adverse H adversarial
nature of so much of the reporting it
was a very hard story to report with the
array of forces lined up against me
fueled by the milk and money I'm just
thrilled to have it done and I'm I'm
just so happy that it did get out and
again you know looking at all the money
that was spent to stop it and you know
there's some private detective has been
going around trying to find you know
damaging things out about me a variation
on this whole County Brock story none of
it has worked and the book is out there
and I feel great about that
having done a story that was this
engaging and consuming my impulses I
didn't want to start on anything else
that wouldn't somehow be as fascinating
as this so I guess I'll sit back and
watch for a while to see what comes
along what do you think of this process
having to talk it out I think it's
always a little difficult for
for a rider to to set to sort of take
your your creation and then try to
reduce it into sort of summary
statements I'm not I like your show
because I think it probably encourages
people to get to the book itself and and
spend some time with it but the process
of reducing what is a very complicated
story
I think risks overs over simplifying it
so I may be a little bit uncomfortable
about it I'm also the kind of journalist
so I like the facts to speak for
themselves I don't like to be the one to
draw too many conclusions because I
think people will be more moved and and
will react more powerfully if they draw
the conclusions the facts are there and
it points to some some obvious things
that they can decide for themselves and
I'd like to think they don't need me to
sit here and like tell them how to think
about it
what if you were list one thing about
this book that has gotten the most
attention what would it be
it's the level of Milken's criminality
again I've known what's going to be in
this book for some time so I wasn't
prepared for the the strength of the
reaction to it and I think it's a
measure of how successful the very
expensive Milken PR campaign was that so
many Americans to this day think either
didn't really do anything wrong or did
something only very minor and very
technical I think you see in the book a
very clearly set forth and you know
logical case that just shows him day
after day insider trading and then
building crimes on top of that a massive
criminal scheme that seems of attracted
the most attention
what do you surprised that people
haven't picked up two things one the the
story of the government blackmailing
Marty Segal which to me is just it's a
it's like a out of a spinal or something
the the drama of it but also the broader
policy questions I mentioned and then
I'm surprised people haven't focused as
much on Segal perhaps because as I
pointed out in the beginning of the four
main characters I think he's shown the
most remorse and has been transformed
and yet to me what's often interesting
and a narrative are the characters who
change the most
I mean milk and is a criminal in the
beginning of the book
and although he's pleaded guilty he
still is in denial at the end of the
book where Seagal goes through to me a
very fascinating past process of
reflection and remorse where do you
think he'll end up I think he'll he'll
have a successful career I think he's
probably he has to heat everyone
acknowledges people had tremendous
abilities and could have been enormously
successful without turning to crime but
I think Seagal won't do it again and I
think he'll be successful so what the
book looks like it's called the den of
thieves it's written by James B Stewart
our guest on booknotes thank you very
much for joining us pleasure